when it comes to Trump they've kind of
almost run out of all their bullets
they've done the racist thing and the
chauvinist thing and every other racial
epiy they could use for him now it's the
threat to democracy that's why I said
earlier or started to say I worry about
the True Believers of this craziness
that will try to kill him because no
other bullets work against him you're
out yeah they've done the legal stuff
they've done the raids the FBI all of it
yeah and it doesn't work it doesn't work
so so uh Glenn are you cuz we've talked
about this uh multiple times with all
this predictive programming that they
keep shoving in our faces it's almost as
if they're warning us that something to
come if they can't cuz I mean I'm and I
genuinely feel that in my heart they're
number one thing if they could they
could take him out if this was this like
oh yeah if this was JFK time and there
wasn't more than one zuder 1,000% they
would have tried to take this guy out